hey this i don't want to spend a lot of
time on this it's it's quite dense it's
worth reading on your own
but propublica did a really interesting
study of the richest richest americans
and what they looked at is how much
in taxes the richest americans paid
relative to how much their wealth grew
during the same time period now
a lot of this has to do with unrealized
gains and i'm going to explain that in a
moment but this is one of the ways in
which the rich
really benefit the super super super
rich i'm not talking about people who
make
500k a year here talking about the super
super rich
um in the united states when you
have an increase in net worth this could
be because
you earned money by working or you might
have an increase in net worth because
assets you hold
increased in value if you hold a bunch
of stocks a million dollars in stocks
and they go up and they're worth
two million dollars in stocks your net
worth just went up by a million dollars
you don't owe any taxes other than on
the dividends
depending on what type of account those
funds or stocks are held in right so but
the gist of it is you don't owe any
taxes on that
gain of a million dollars in net worth
until you realize the gain
by selling those stocks so what you've
seen
over the last uh from 2014 to 2018
is that the 25 richest americans saw
their collective
net worth go up by 400 billion dollars
but they only paid 13.6 billion dollars
in federal income taxes so that is a 3.4
percent
now i know many people are going to say
david david hold on
uh they didn't have a taxable event a
lot of that growth and net worth
came from they held assets and the
assets went up in value if i have a
two million dollar house and the market
explodes and it's worth four million
my net worth went up two million dollars
i don't owe any taxes on that
okay my real estate taxes might go up a
little if the assessment goes up right
there's some details
that's how it works david i understand
but the analysis is an interesting one
nonetheless which is
when you were already very wealthy you
were able to
increase your net worth with very little
tax exposure for the
average person if you make 50 000
a year and you get a raise to 75 000
a year that's a nice raise that increase
in the net worth you could have
by saving your additional salary is
going to be dragged down by the fact
that you're paying income taxes
on that additional salary so the the
investigation is
an interesting one because it exposes
the
tax on net worth growth which is
really really low now am i proposing a
particular change in policy as a result
of this no i have other segments on that
but it's a very interesting way to look
at how by not realizing gains
and by having assets that grow
that are disproportionately already held
by the very rich you can have
a net worth grow with extremely low drag
from taxes
tax drag as it is often called and it is
another one of the ways in which just
increasing income taxes which is often
what the discussion is it's what we're
talking about now with joe biden
does very very little to actually
capture
the vast majority of the benefit to the
ultra ultra ultra rich we're talking
about
multi-billionaires here this is a very
different thing
than someone with a small business like
joe the plumbers which supposedly made
250 000 a year but didn't actually
very very different situation if you've
been watching the show you've probably
heard me talk about how much i love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you 20 off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up it's
solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room their
prices are very reasonable and when you
get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now
and get 20 percent off your entire order
when you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video